[Music]
now yawn you always have so much going
you're constantly on the road with the
band
you've got the store the record label
the radio program yawn Livan flavored
vodka and now yawn Levon European tools
[Music]
Livan always expanding when I was little
boy in Poland all the times I dreaming
at America you're invest had built all
my business you cannot go wrong with
this man he never stops we went in we
get the beach
that Java that learning with did real
good managed today
oh nice and thick nice and thick my
favorite size see on the bus Ronnie
Oh mister the one you know while I'm
here
yes he's very good investment to help
build Empire oh no I'm not here to
invest what you're doing is illegal
as of today yep you've all that money
back to your investors today today are
some other today how I make all this
money we want to invest more in genuine
show gifts something's going on
no nothing on everything good you do
anything to hurt this family I will
destroy you
okay no no no no I just need fill up
papers and forms
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
it's America we all get second chance
[Music]
sick
[Music]